let's talk about the economy and
specifically the stock market because as
you know if you've been watching or
listening to the show for a while I've
told you many times that the stock
market does better under Democratic
presidents than under republican
presidents if you go back to nineteen
forty-five the average annual gain of
the stock market under Democratic
presidents is nine point seven percent
and under republican presidents it's six
point seven percent per year now you
might say to me well David you're
tricking us by starting in 1945 well now
let's go back further to 1901 starting
with Teddy Roosevelt the average
democratic again per year in the stock
market is seven percent the average
Republican gain in the stock market per
year is three percent these are just the
numbers and Wall Street has felt for a
long time that Hillary Clinton would
easily defeat Donald Trump but now that
Trump has been sort of surging from
behind the race has been tightening with
just a few days to go stock markets are
tentative it has not been a particularly
good week for stocks in Europe some
individual stock markets are also on the
decline presumably because of Trump
fears the S&P 500 yesterday was down 13
points to the UH what's called the key
support level of 2097 now I don't want
to overstate the importance of the stock
market right i mean i understand like
many in our audience that number one
only about half of all americans even
own any stocks and of that half that do
the overwhelming portion of those stocks
are held by the few the rich the one
percent so i get that and number two I
get that the stock market is not the
indicator of economic health period it
only impacts part of the country it only
reflects certain areas of society but it
is sort of funny to me that the
corporate apparatus would have more
faith in the 30-year politician rather
than the guy running on how great of a
businessman he is and this actually Pat
says a lot about Trump and Clinton
number one it shows that Trump as the
business guy is not inspiring a lot of
confidence in the biggest businesses of
the country but it also shows
shows that Hillary Clinton clearly is
feeling like a safe bet for Wall Street
in many ways which by the way is no
surprise she is a plutocratic oligarch
type and we've covered that extensively
well I think investors would be
concerned if Trump wins because he's
talked about defaulting on the national
debt yeah as a good business move he
seems to think that uh business
decisions transfer over well to the
economy of the country it just doesn't
go like that there's no evidence
whatsoever that good business people
make good presidents there's no evidence
whatsoever that running the country like
a private business is a good way to run
the country what there is evidence for
is that not not only does the economy do
far better in terms of the stock market
under Democratic presidents than
Republican presidents GDP Rises
significantly more when you have a
Democrat in the White House versus a
Republican 4.3 percent versus 2.5% the
unemployment rate on average is lower
under Democrats than under Republicans
five point six percent versus six
percent real wages have increased
slightly faster under Democrats than
under Republicans not statistically
significant about the same but just a
little bit better and the country
historically has been more likely more
often in a recession while a Republican
president is in office versus a
Democratic president so that's the data
you might not like it you might not like
me you might not like my shirt but
that's the data and my shirt or my face
or whatever Pat's doing over there
doesn't change this reality and this is
real tough for some people in our
audience Pat they don't want to accept
the reality give me a different opinion
about what is the cause of this but
that's just the truth Pat these are the
facts yeah I mean if he runs his
businesses if he runs the country like
he runs his businesses will be bankrupt
pretty soon what we can expect more of
the same uh defaulting on the national
debt backing out of trade deals
unilaterally which would violate all
sorts of agreements and policies we did
none of it makes sense ladies and
gentlemen please wake up this is all a
farce send me your thoughts i'm on
twitter at d pakman many in our audience
know that my girlfriend is
guitar Ian she is vegetarian plus fish
and seafood and you've probably also
heard me mention that I am a big
advocate of the Mediterranean diet and
what that means is since I am having
chicken and steak less often when I do
have them I really want to feel like
it's worth it and I'm having something
good and I have really been enjoying
having the Omaha Steaks family grill
pack in my freezer so that when I want a
great steak I can grab one of the filet
mignons or one of the top sirloins are
one of the other items that came with it
for 4999 using my coupon code at Omaha
Steaks dot-com which I will tell you
about and even my girlfriend is starting
to she's fascinated by when I say oh you
know what and tomorrow I'm gonna make
one of the steaks take it out of the
freezer put it in the fridge to defrost
it overnight the whole process that I've
developed and i have to tell you she
she's quite curious for a pescetarian
about what i have going on with these
steaks that I move from my freezer to my
fridge when I'm ready to cook them and
you can take advantage of the 4999
discount price on the Omaha Steaks
family grill pack by going to Omaha
Steaks dot-com and using my code Pakman
in the search bar you type in PA que ma
n and then you can add the discounted
family grill pack to your cart I've been
enjoying it I think you will too let me
know if you order it I want to hear from
you